the Joe Rogan experience so yeah this
anarchy thing like how serious are you
about that 100% 100% sir yes
so anarchists think there should be no
cops know that anarchists don't think
this should be government cops there's
private security Oh
private security whoops before what well
same thing you if no one wants to have a
like if you go to a bar you're not
paying for the doorman or if you're
going to a hotel you're not paying for
security the point is whoever has an
environment wants it to be as safe as
possible okay stop right there okay
because if you go into a bar if you're
buying a drink
the bar is taking some of the money from
that drink to pay for that security act
it's the same thing as you paying taxes
it's not the same fancy pink text so
let's just look at it this way it's just
money into a pool it's not just like oh
please if you throw the money into a
pool but let me explain okay if you
throw the money into the pool okay
and obviously taxes get taken from you
it's different in that regard but if you
have a certain amount of money certain
amount of money is gonna go to
protecting the people and this is the
idea of police force and this is the
idea of a bouncer at least a bouncer is
more likely acting in the interest of
the club and trying to keep out bad
people they're gonna keep people from
getting sued but the money for the
drinks goes to that some of it a
percentage goes that sure much like you
tax money some of it goes to the cops
sure right correct
but the big difference is one is
voluntary and one is forceful and one is
a monopoly and one isn't so if you had a
free system you would have more security
because the streets would have someone
doing security and the bar and the store
and there would be complimentary to each
other as opposed to you only have two
down on one one wouldn't it look how
many dating sites there all right would
it be great if instead of one number you
had dozens of places that are going to
offer you security
so like private businesses that work
like uber you give them a call when you
getting raped like you press a button a
short one with the dude we hang on you
press a button and then someone shows up
we have that now and right we have no I
mean we if you go to a apartment
building or a business building there's
gonna be security there already
you're not gonna yeah you're not gonna
call the cops are gonna call the
downstairs we're just book readers
shirts and they're playing with their
phone they used to
book readers to other phone players well
I'd rather they be reading books than
shooting dogs so that's where we are
right
Suzanne in terms that's the grossest
[ __ ] ever when you see SWAT teams show
up and yes people's dogs and people get
and that's the problem with having a
monopoly is there's no consequences yes
so let's say there's all these cases
where you know dogs get shot the flash
grenade in the baby's crib
these people aren't fight like a Eric
Gardner the only person who got in
trouble for Eric garner dying is the guy
who filmed it mm-hmm I mean if you are a
cook and you are serving food and you
undercooked chicken it's a mistake
honest mistake and someone gets sick
that shouldn't be your job but if you're
a police officer often and I'm going to
get a lot of heat for this and that's
fine if you something bad happens as a
consequence of reactions there have to
be consequences that maybe this isn't
the right job for you well oftentimes
there is if there's an inappropriate
shooting or subclone those lines but I
think you're right and I mean I've
experienced abusive cops I think we all
have and I also think that it's very
very very difficult to be that guy
absolutely and not become abusive and
not become worn out by it not become
extremely stressed out I'm a big
supporter of police I just don't think
that it's a job for everybody I think
being a cop is like a lot of other jobs
that are especially that one that's
super [ __ ] difficult the idea to just
hire people off the street and run them
through some tests and they're gonna
make great cops I agree it's crazy
I agree and what happens is when you're
a monopoly you don't have to be
efficient or effective
I think they should hire former military
that's what I think at least eight hire
people no hire people that have
discipline hire people that that have
gone through some experience in actual
combat who know how to handle pressure
better and then make it a very very
valuable job and make it a very like
very strict codes of conduct and and
behavior and an action I think another
problem that police have in their
defense is when you have public streets
people have certain rights and they can
act have where they're like here in LA
you have only seen these tents and I
think my understanding is the government
said you can't clear out those tents
that is hilarious isn't it and now the
cops can't do anything so they are
hamstrung from being able to do their
jobs whereas if this was private this
would not be happening